I've always felt like my dad didn't
really love me
okay
and then now when I went and met him in
Switzerland I was like no
he's just Swiss
they're all like that
I I tried I tried to surprise him though
right I tried to surprise him by
learning German we hadn't seen each
other for a while and because he speaks
German I thought I was going to surprise
him on the trip you know I went on
Duolingo did a bunch of studying then
got to Switzerland was like oh this is
it and I was ready I was like I want to
surprise my dad I plan to get to his
house knock on the door he was going to
open and be surprised like oh Trevor
then I'll be like Papa espresso Deutsch
he's gonna be like
this
there's gonna be a whole thing I had it
all planned out
didn't go according to plan
I got there he was surprised he was
happy but as soon as I spoke I was like
Papa espresso Deutsch and he was like
don't do that don't do that huh